c'est un homme de 27 ans qui depuis hier
a été placé en détention provisoire pour
homicide volontaire suite à sa garde à
vue il s'agit du fils du propriétaire de
la maison où a été retrouvée la victime
gilles marie josèphe connu des services
de police pour fait usage de stupéfiants
il avait été arrêté suite à la
découverte du corps
il reconnaît avoir porté des coups mais
sans l' usage d'armes une incohérence
avec les résultats de l'autopsié les
premières constatations médico légales
qui ont été réalisées on permis déjà
d'apprendre que la victime avait été
violentée et présentait plusieurs
blessures en différents en différents
lieux de en différentes parties de son
corps et que notamment il y aurait une
blessure au niveau de l'artère fémorale
qui pourrait être la blessure mortelle
plusieurs objets pourraient avoir été
utilisées dont au moins un en comptant
dans la participation du père dans un
premier temps placé en garde à vue est à
ce stade de l'enquêté cartes et quant
aux suspicions de séquestration elles ne
sont pour l'instant pas confirmé mais
des résultats plus approfondie de
l'autopsié sont attendus
quelle a été l'enchaînement précis les
différents actes de violence et
notamment y at il eu au cours des jours
précédents d'autres actes de violence
tout cela elle reste encore à établir
par le magistrat ce quart et d'autres
résultats de l'autopsié sont attendus
pourraient apporter des éclairages sur
cinq ans absolument et elle a pour
l'instant nous n'avons que que des
résultats très provisoire le suspect
encourt 30 ans de réclusion criminelle